[Music]
well the new york times is under fire
over
its coverage of thousands of cuban
protesters of the weekend demanding an
end to communist dictatorship the times
tweeting
shouting freedom and other
anti-government slogans hundreds of
cubans took to the streets in cities
around the country on sunday
to protest food and medicine shortages
in a remarkable eruption
of discontent not seen in nearly 30
years are here to react to
the host of unfiltered dan bongino dan
this caught me by surprise what about
you
yeah not at all i mean you won't see a
tweet that
better summarizes the massive divide
between the ideological right and the
ideological left
in america today you know the great uh
economist philosopher thomas saul
has a book conflict divisions it's an
older book but it summarizes this how
these two visions
one on the conservative right and the
other on the far left
they can't there's no overlap anymore
the visions are totally different
think about it right that tweet sums it
up right there in in the real world we
live in the freedom and liberty loving
constitutional republic
the government brian doesn't give you
freedoms does everybody understand that
those freedoms are granted to you by god
they are big our rights god-given rights
the government can only en ensure that
those freedoms
are codified and codified in the
constitution and the law
it doesn't give you anything the way the
left sees it in their vision of the
world
is that that freedom is somehow granted
to you by government
hence the tweet by the new york times
again the tweet sums up the whole divide
in america today
well you know what as we look at the
video and and it wasn't hundreds uh
other news outfits said it was thousands
of protesters
uh but dan according to a state
department spokesperson and their
twitter
the reason people were uprising is
because of covet
it's not about that they are living in a
communist regime for 60 years
it's because but it's coveted which the
administration blames for everything
well it's a continuation of the 70 and
80 year uh
excuse me dec 80 year eight decades nine
decades long
uh effort by the media and others and
and the illiberal left
to cover up for the stain on human
society of communism socialism and
totalitarianism
they don't really want you to know why
these people are in the streets and it
reminds me of a subject
i discussed on my weekend show here on
fox i brought up this weekend
i said listen guys the desire to
suppress human liberties like keeping a
beach ball underwater eventually your
arms get tired
it will never overcome the desire by
free human beings
to embrace and jealously guard their
freedom of liberty you know you can use
power and force as much as you want but
eventually as you see on the screen
right now
people are going to go to the streets
and say i was born free i'm not asking
you for anything
get out of our way our freedom is ours
god gave it to us not you
that's why it was so important for us to
be successful with the image
with something to aspire to uh and if
we're
turning on ourselves the ripple effect
around the world
is unquantifiable the damage that it
could do yeah
dan i know you got a radio show podcast
to recover
uh i need uh to uh record so we'll
recover from
and recover recover from the weekend and
go record your podcast
no i know i i look forward to monday
listen i look forward to it the weekends
i i had a little uh
you know relaxing weekend so i'm all
fired up today about this specific topic
just remember that i'm serious the
desire to squelch human liberty
you know it'll never ever match the
energy of people who just want to yearn
to be free
no matter what that bernie sanders
thanks so much great to see you